Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Pock!
Aber Mittwoch eine Projekt-Präsentation, Pog.
Ist es ein GIF oder ein GIF?
Auch wenn der Erfinder angeblich mal GIF gesagt hat, manchmal wissen auch Erfinder nicht Bescheid über ihr eigenes Zeug.
Was hast du denn für ein Projekt gemacht, GiantMaster95?
Wieso, reicht doch. Scheiß drauf, reicht.
Ganz ehrlich, Hauptsache du bestehst, Note, who cares, ja.
Ernsthaft? Wirklich? Die haben die verloren.
Aber wenn du neu schreiben darfst, heißt das du schreibst eine andere Prüfung oder die gleiche nochmal?
Das ist ein Haufen inkompetenter Volldeppen.
LightSale, woher sollst du wissen, dass LightSale für irgendwelche oder Beanstalk irgendwas mit Ruby zu tun hat und sowas?
Die Alastik Container Registration lässt du eine Image aufladen, die andere Tools wie der Alastik Container Service übernehmen, um sie wieder zurückzulassen.
ECS ist ein API für Starten, Stoppen und Verkauf der virtuellen Maschinen zu deinen Containern und lässt dich sie zu anderen Produkten wie Loadbalancern verbinden.
Some companies may want more control over how their app scales, in which case EKS is a tool for running Kubernetes
But in other cases, you may want your containers to behave in a more automated way
Fargate is a tool that will make your contain...
Alter wer plickt ja da noch durch?
...behave like serverless functions. Removing the need to allocate EC2 instances for your...
Azure on-prem, nein das haben wir nicht
...containers, but if you're building an application and already have it containerized, the easiest way to deploy it to AWS...
Okay, das hat man wenigstens im Namen, wo man sich was darunter vorstellen kann
...where you simply point it to a container image, while it handles all the orchestration and scaling behind the scenes
But running an application is only half the battle. We also need to store data in the cloud. Simple storage service, or S3, was the very first product offered by AWS
Ja, das kenn ich. Das ist glaube ich das einzige, wo von jeder schon mal irgendwie was gehört hat, was von Amazon Cloud gedönst am Start ist
It can store any type of file or object, like an image or video, and it's based on the same infrastructure as Amazon's e-commerce site
It's great for general purpose file storage, but if you don't access your files very often, you can archive them in Glacier, which has a higher latency, but...
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding. Niemand kann sich das in Zusammenhang merken, dass die File Archivierung, also, könnte das nicht einfach AWS Archive nennen oder so, dann weißt du wenigstens, wie es heißt
Ja, ja
Ja
Aber wie about you, wei?
Das ist ja so eng roadwork
provides all the bells and whistles,
but at a much higher cost.
In addition to raw files,
developers also need to store structured data
for their end users.
And that brings us to our database aisle,
which has a lot of different products.
Man sollte es nicht so wie wir machen
für 80.000 Euro SSDs dranhängen.
The first ever database on AWS
was SimpleDB. Im Monat, im Monat.
A general purpose, no SQL database.
But it tends to be a little too simple for most people.
Everybody knows you never go full retard.
It was followed up a few years later
when DynamoDB, which is a document database,
that's very easy to scale horizontally.
It's inexpensive and provides...
CosmoDB, Cosmos, Cosmo?
Ich kann mir nicht merken, wie es bei Azure heißt,
aber die haben auch so Zeug.
Fast read performance,
but it isn't very good at modeling relational data.
If you're familiar with MongoDB,
another document database option is DocumentDB.
It's a controversial option that's technically not MongoDB
that has a one-to-one mapping of the MongoDB API
to get around restrictive open source licensing.
Speaking of which, Amazon also did a similar thing
with Elasticsearch, which itself is a great option
if you want to build something...
By the way, das Produkt heißt wirklich Elasticsearch.
Es hat nichts mit diesem Elastic zu tun,
was Amazon sonst überall dran pappt vom Namen her.
...which itself is a great option
if you want to build something like a full-text search engine.
But the majority of developers out there
will opt for a traditional relational SQL database.
Amazon relational database...
Da haben die sich drüber beschwert bei Elasticsearch.
Dass das zu ähnlich an ihrem Namen dran ist.
Da gab's richtig Stress vor so einem halben Jahr.
RDS supports a variety of different SQL flavors
and can fully manage things like backups...
Oh, oh!
Leute, der Teufel!
Zweite von rechts!
Fällt mir jetzt erst auf!
Gehst du weg?
...patch in and scale.
But Amazon also offers its own proprietary flavor
of SQL called Aurora.
It's compatible with Postgres or MySQL
and can be operated with better performance at a lower cost.
In addition, Aurora offers a new serverless option
that makes it even easier to scale
and you only pay for the actual time...
Mein Gehirn ist durch jetzt nach dem Video.
Relational databases are a great general purpose option,
but they're not the only option.
Neptune is a graph database
that can achieve better performance
on highly connected datasets
like a social graph or recommendation engine.
If your current database is too slow,
you may want to bring in Elastic Cache,
which is a fully managed version of Redis.
...der wiederum nichts mit Elastic Search zu tun hat.
Man darf sich das jetzt nicht...
Also wer jetzt etwa denkt,
dass Elastic Search und Elastic Cache
was mit manner zu tun haben?
Nee, nee, nee, nee!
...an in-memory database
that delivers data to your end users
with extremely low latency.
If you work with time series data,
like the stock market, for example,
you may benefit from Timestream,
a time series database
with built-in functions for time-based queries
and additional features for analytics.
Yet another option is the Quantum Ledger Database,
which allows you to build an enable set
of cryptographically signed transactions...
Das hört ja gar nicht mal auf!
...to decentralize blockchain technology.
Now let's shift gears and talk about analytics.
To analyze data, you first need a place to store it,
and a popular option for doing that is Redshift,
which is a data warehouse
that tries to get you to shift away from Oracle.
Warehouses are often used by big enterprises
to dump multiple data sources from the business
where they can be analyzed together.
When all your data is in one place,
it's easier to generate meaningful analytics
in order to keep learning on it.
Data in a warehouse is structured so it can be queried,
but if you need a place to put a large amount of unstructured data,
you can use...
Wo ist jetzt der Unterschied
zwischen der normalen Datenbank und Redshift?
Ich mein, in der normalen Datenbank
kann ich auch Sachen querien.
Oder ist das so eine Metadatenbank
über andere Datenbanken drüber?
Oder wie?
Oder was?
Oder wo?
...like formation,
which is a tool for creating data lakes or repositories
that store a large amount of unstructured data,
which can be used in addition to data warehouses to query...
Unstructured data?
Man könnte auch einfach einen Fileshare machen
für unstructured data.
...a larger variety of data sources.
If you want to analyze real-time data,
you can use Kinesis to capture real-time streams
from your infrastructure,
then visualize them in your favorite business intelligence tool.
Or you can use a stream processing framework
like Apache Spark that runs on Elastic MapReduce,
which itself is a service that allows you to operate
on massive data sets efficiently
with a parallel distributed algorithm.
Now, if you don't want to use Kinesis for streaming data,
a popular alternative is Apache Kafka.
It's open-sourced and Amazon...
Das ist der neueste Shit aktuell.
Kafka Message Queue, Giddy-on-Star,
stehen sie alle grad rauf.
...is a fully managed service to get you started.
But for the average developer,
all this data processing may be a little too complicated.
Glue is a serverless product that makes it much easier...
Das hört gar nicht mehr auf.
...to transform and load your data.
It can automatically connect to other data sources on AWS,
like Aurora, Redshift, and S3.
Alles klar, alles klar, okay.
So you can create jobs without having to write any actual source code.
But one of the biggest advantages of collecting massive amounts of data
is that you can use it to help predict the future.
Oh, blockchain, big-train AI.
...machine learning aisle to make that process easier.
But first, if you don't have any high-quality data of your own,
you can use the data exchange to purchase and subscribe to data
from third-party sources.
Once you have some data in the cloud,
you can use SageMaker to connect to it
and start building machine learning models with TensorFlow or PyTorch.
It operates on multiple levels to make machine learning easier...
...and provides a managed Jupyter Notebook that can connect to...
Too smart.
...to train a machine learning model, then deploy it somewhere useful.
That's cool, but building your own ML models from scratch
is still extremely difficult.
If you need to do image analysis,
you may as well just use the Rekognition API.
It can classify all kinds of objects and images
and is likely way better than anything that you would build on your own.
Gibt's auch Leute, die alles... Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Or if you want to build a conversational bot, you might use Lex,
which runs on the same technology that powers Alexa devices.
Or if you just want to have fun and learn how machine learning works,
you might buy a DeepRacer device.
Was?
...that you can drive with your own machine...
Jetzt ernsthaft, Leute.
Bis zu diesem Video, wusste ihr, dass das überhaupt existiert?
Habt ihr davon jemals schon was gehört, bevor ihr dieses Video gesehen habt?
...and look at a few other essential tools that are used by a wide variety of developers.
For security, we have IM, where you can create rules...
Ich auch nicht....and determine who has access to what on your AWS account.
If you're building a web or mobile app where users can log into your account...
Cognito....or users can log into your account...
Cognito is a tool that enables them to log in with a variety of different authentication methods...
...and manages the user sessions for you.
Then once you have a few users logged into your app, you may want to send them push notifications.
SNS is a tool that can get that job done.
Or maybe you want to say...
Dank Apple ist Push Notifications ja immer noch ein unglaublich beschissen kompliziertes Problem.
...send emails to your users.
SES is the tool for that.
Now that you know about all these tools, you're going to want an organized way to provision them.
CloudFormation is a way to create templates based on your infrastructure...
Das ist im Prinzip so was wie Terraform nur von Amazon selbst.
...or JSON.
...it's allowing you to make hundreds of different services with the single click of a button.
From there, you'll likely want to interact with those services from a front-end application like iOS, Android, or the web.
Amplify provides SDKs that can connect to your infrastructure from JavaScript frameworks and other front-end applications.
Now the final thing to remember is that all this is going to cost you a ton of money, which goes directly to getting Jeff's rocket up.
So make sure to use AWS Cost Explorer and Budgets if you don't want to pay for these big bulging rockets.
That's the end of the video.
It took a ton of work, so please like and subscribe to support the channel, we'll become a pro member at Fireship.io.
Also du hast keine Notification-AP im Browser.
Safari ist mal wieder hinten dran, was das angeht.
Bin jetzt kein großer Android-Fan, noch großartiger Apple-Verfechter, aber gerade was Web-Technologien angeht,
sind die bei Safari einfach irgendwo vor fünf Jahren mal stehen geblieben.
Gerade auch die PWA-Unterstützung von Safari ist ja in Ansätzen vorhanden.
Vergleich zur Magenta-Cloud ist das gar nichts.
Ja, die Magenta-Cloud ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Ich habe ja mal auf so einer Azure-Schule gefragt, weil er gemeint hat, ja, man kann auch super Daten migrieren von anderen Clouds und sonst wie.
Da habe ich ihn gefragt, und wie sieht es aus mit der Magenta-Cloud? Da hat er einfach nur gelacht und nichts dazu gesagt.
Also für diesen Microsoft-Trainer war die Magenta-Cloud schon so lächerlich, dass er gedacht hat, er muss da nicht mal drauf antworten.
Doch, ich glaube, das ist OpenStack-Telekom, ja, das kann sein.
Ich habe schon öfters gesehen, dass die OpenStack-Leute suchen.
Aber gut, es ist ein Microsoft-Trainer, warum soll der auch was zur Magenta-Cloud sagen?
Echt? Wirklich? Es gibt Leute, die das benutzen. Warum?
Warum habt ihr euch für Magenta-Cloud entschieden?
Äh, ja, sagt mir irgendwas.
Genau, ja, nee, habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Das gucken wir uns, das gucken wir uns, das gucken wir uns demnächst mal an.
Zumindest mal kurz.
So, nächsten Tag gucken wir uns, spätestens am Wochenende gucken wir uns die Insider-Preview an, die neue.
Wie ist halt Google Cloud? Also bei uns ist alles Azure.
Letztendlich ist es aber auch fast egal, ob Google Cloud oder AWS oder Microsoft.
Ist auch ein paar Feinheiten, kannst du überall die Basics machen.
Und mehr.
Problem ist nur, dass man nicht mehr durchblickt.
Okay.
Wollte ich gerade noch irgendwas beantworten? Hat vorhin jemand gefragt, was?
Nee, das habe ich nicht gelesen, aber irgendwas anderes.
Azure hat wilde Fehlermeldungen, ja.
Irgendjemand hat doch eben was langes gefragt.
Also, was mich die Woche richtig abgefuckt hat, wir brauchen ein kleines Tool.
Das sollte nur ein paar Dateien manipulieren und das sollte relativ performant laufen.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt es nicht in C++ gemacht.
Das ist dann zwar schnell, aber keiner blickt durch.
Oder in Kobol, ihr hättet es in Kobol machen sollen.
Egal, anstatt sich da mal moderne Technologien, Kobol, Kobol, Kobol, beste.
Und etwas Expertises damit aufzumachen, wird das einfach in Java geschrieben.
Na ja, es ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Du kannst die Sachen auch ziemlich schnell in Java machen.
Du musst halt wissen, was du machst.
Also, ganz ehrlich, Java hat zwar einen schlechten Ruf.
Das liegt aber zum größten Teil an Leuten, die nicht Java programmieren können.
Sage ich jetzt einfach, weil ich kann auch kein Java programmieren.
Ich kann es zwar lesen und ich könnte es wahrscheinlich auch programmieren, aber ich mache es so gut
wie nie.
Aber dass viele Java-Softer so kacke ist, das liegt an den Programmierern gar nicht
so sehr an Java selbst.
Vielleicht fördert es das auch ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht.
Aber einfach Sachen schnell in Java machen ist kein Problem.
Also Java ist relativ zackig.
Java ist nicht so, das ist nicht langsam.
Ich habe, was in C Sharp programmiert letztens, übertragen wir das mal auf Java, wir haben
irgendeine Log-Auswertung machen müssen und da hat jemand, da hat ein Kollege von mir
auf der Arbeit einen Bash-Script zusammen gewurstet, was ganz wild ist, mit verschiedenen
Dateien, wo dann MD5-Summen gespeichert wurden, zu unterverzeichnissen, zu frag mich nicht,
ganz, ganz wildes Zeug.
So, und die hatten das Problem, dass das quasi schon in der Testumgebung, glaube ich, 5 Tage
oder so gelaufen ist, bis, ich kriege es nicht mehr genau zusammen, ich sage jetzt einfach
5 Tage gelaufen ist, bis es ein Ergebnis hatte.
So, da bin ich hingegangen, habe ein.NET Core Programm gemacht, halt ordentlich Multithreaded,
das Ding lief ja auf einer, glaube ich, 48 Core Kiste und ich habe es noch limitiert
auf irgendwie 40, 40 Threads und habe das durchflutschen lassen, das war in 30 Minuten
fertig.
Also das Bash Ding lief 5 Tage, das.NET Programm lief, keine Ahnung, eine Viertelstunde, 20,
30 Minuten.
Also das ist in Java, wäre das genauso möglich.
Man muss einfach wissen, was man da programmiert, das Zeug ist schnell genug.
Sogar JavaScript, hey, JavaScript ist viel schneller als alle denken, JavaScript ist eigentlich
eines der schnellsten Sprachen, die es so gibt, ich meine, wir reden jetzt nicht von Rust
oder C oder sowas, aber JavaScript ist jetzt nicht so viel langsamer als die schnellsten,
also ich würde mal sagen, der Unterschied, also bei normalem Zeugs, ich rede jetzt nicht
von irgendwelchem hochoptimierten Inline Assembler C mit CPU, Caches und bla bla bla,
also von normalem Zeug, weil wenn man das da drin macht, dann ist JavaScript nicht so
viel bedeutend langsamer, wie sagen wir mal ein C oder C++ Programm, vielleicht 2, 3
mal langsamer, es sei denn, man trifft auf einen JavaScript Bug, dass der dieser Hotpass
JIT Compiler oder sowas, was wir da haben, dass der das nicht ordentlich optimieren kann,
dann ist es viel viel langsamer.
JavaScript ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, das stimmt wohl, aber das Problem haben wir hier im Stream nicht, weil ich meine,
es kann ja keiner ernsthaft behaupten, dass das hier in irgendeiner Art und Weise schlecht
wartbar wäre, also das ist ja wohl wirklich komplett selbsterklärend, komplett ohne Kommentare
lesbar und zu verstehen, ich glaube, da gibt es keine Fragen mehr, also die müssten einfach
alle mehr bei mir im Stream gucken und schauen, wie man sowas macht, gerade heute, ich meine
gerade heute war der Sauce Code besonders besonders besonders hübsch, die Hex Code, ja klar,
sowas macht es immer besonders lesbar, wobei an der Stelle sind die sogar halbwegs gescheit
benannt, weißt du wenigstens, was es macht, push mal, ne jetzt nicht.
Was, was, was, was, was, was, was bin ich denn hier am sehen gerade?
Irgendeiner Rust und Javascript vergleicht oder so, na gut kann man ja machen, Dank Web
Assembly.
Leider ist vieles in Web Assembly noch nicht so schnell, wie es sein könnte, das wird noch
besser.
Es wird immer besser.
Hehehehe, Udemy Kurs, null, wozu soll ich einen Udemy Kurs verkaufen, mir gucken mittlerweile
auch bei so abgedrehten Sachen wie heute 300 Leute auf Twitch zu, da verdiene ich mit Saps
ja mehr als mit einem Udemy Kurs, außerdem bin ich viel zu faul, einen Kurs zu erstellen,
ich hab die Woche Bash Code gesehen, damit man, ja, ja, kann man, kann man, kann man,
wisst ihr was das ekligste auf der Welt, also was richtig eklig ist als Bash, in Bash
Array Syntax, guckt euch das mal an, ja, ist das, ist das nicht fein, achja und das hier,
und das hier, und das hier, die einen sind Elemente und sowas, und zum, zum, zum, für
eine Schleife drüber dann natürlich so, bitteschön, ja, und genauso, nicht anders, richtig agil,
ja, das ist Bash, Bash Array Syntax, verwendet man aber eigentlich auch so gut wie nie.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass vieles in WebAssembly oder zumindest so, was
ich da in letzter Zeit drüber gelesen habe, gerade wenn du DOM Zugriffe brauchst in WebAssembly
viel, viel langsamer ist als in JavaScript, oder je nachdem, welche Sprache du verwendest,
dass in WebAssembly oftmals immer noch langsamer ist, also standardmäßig noch langsamer ist
als in JavaScript, ja, oh, Pearl ist auch richtig Payne's Champ, ich hab Pearl in meinem ersten
Vorstellungsgespräch erwähnt, was, da ging's drum so, was ich so Programmiersprachenmäßig
schon gemacht hab und so, da hab ich damals gesagt, Pearl, obwohl ich mit Pearl außer
mal die ersten paar Seiten von einem Buch eigentlich gar nix zu tun hatte, aber es hat
funktioniert, die hab ich genommen damals, naja, ich komm mal kurz, wenn wir hosten können,
können wir irgendjemand hosten?
Irgendjemand, der's gebrauchen kann, von dem ich Follower, ne, einer da, ja gut Leute, ich
würd sagen, wir machen dann evtl. sogar morgen schon weiter, das war mir zu big brain, Leute,
was sagt ihr denn zum Stream heute, way too big brain, oder, ich glaub oft, also, kann
ich nicht oft machen, da platzt mein Kopf, also morgen kann ich das noch fertig machen,
also wieder gut, wobei wir das Programm morgen garantiert nicht fertig bekommen werden, morgen
kriegen wir es vielleicht hin, das GIF zu rendern, aber da gehören ja noch Feinheiten
dazu, wie resizing vom Fenster Sound abspielen können und sowas, also, dass dieses Overlay
hier funktioniert und auch Sounds abspielen kann, wie z.B. den hier, ist gar nicht so
einfach, aber ich weiß wie's geht, das kann ich abgucken vom alten, mit FFmpeg, genau,
mit FFmpeg machen wir das, FFmpeg GIF einlesen und dann die einzelnen Bilder mit Direct2D
rendern, ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht, ich mach, also, da hat man ja glaub ich gesehen,
ich hab davon keine Ahnung, ich hab einfach Tutorial durchgebastelt, das passt schon,
das ist kein Problem, Text-to-Speech, das hab ich als WAF gespeichert, alles, muss
ich einfach noch abspielen, alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns bis morgen, c u.